okay so
it it's happening again
it happened to marjorie taylor green and
it is now potentially going to happen to
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
we have seen
numerous videos uncovered in which
lauren bobert implies or alludes to
muslim member of congress ilhan omar
being a terrorist
wearing backpack bombs refers to the
squad as the jihad squad and is
generally a gross person
as a result
uh some democrats are now moving to
strip lauren bobert of all of her
committee assignments is this a good
idea we're going to talk about it first
let's look at examples of what lauren
bobert has been saying
i'm going to play three of them here for
you she has told a very similar story a
few times
here are a few of those versions of the
story
now i've had a little bit of fun in
congress no i haven't gone toe-to-toe
with aoc she doesn't show up to work
sorry she votes by proxy
i did feel han omar the other day and i
said oh cute
the jihad squad decided to come in for
work
one of my staffers
on his first day with me got into an
elevator
in the capitol
and in that in the elevator we were
joined
by ilhan omar
well it was just us three in there and i
looked over and i said
well look at there's the jihad squad
[Applause]
so we're good
actually i have a new hot story for you
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see
fret all over his face and he's reaching
i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it like what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
so this is very vile stuff and as a
result massachusetts democratic
congresswoman ayanna pressley is moving
to have lauren beaubert removed from
every single committee on which she sits
pressly announced her resolution
yesterday morning let's take a look at
that clip
we have heard the hate and credible
threats that have been directed at rep
omar and her staff
words have consequences we must
acknowledge that and respond with action
we've introduced this resolution today
to do just that and to send a powerful
message to every muslim
and every marginalized person who has
ever questioned their place in this
country
or in the halls of power
we see you
you belong
you are powerful
and you deserve a life free from fear
and filled with dignity and love
how we respond in moments like these
will have a lasting impact and history
will remember us for it now
i i have two views on this and i do want
to hear from you about it
on the merits if you just say
does this woman lauren bobert deserve to
be on any committees the answer is of
course not of course not on the merits
she shouldn't be on a single committee
she shouldn't be in congress i wouldn't
trust her to mow my lawn or uh uh
run antivirus software on my computer
you know i don't want to minimize any
any job but what i'm saying is even
simple jobs she has no business i
wouldn't want her doing anything oh
david sir are you saying she shouldn't
earn a living guys let's take it easy
okay she's incompetent
um her presence in the house of
representatives as a legislative body is
a disgrace
but to some degree
is it kind of a pyrrhic victory
when democrats do this
to these very much deserving of it being
done to them republican they did it to
marjorie taylor greene now they're
looking very strongly at doing it to
lauren bobert what do i mean a pyrrhic
victory a pyrrhic victory is a victory
uh which
in so achieving the victory
you do damage to yourself or at the end
of the day you say i won but did i
really win did i really come out ahead
and what i mean by that is the following
republicans are not in the majority
right now regardless so democrats still
control
the committees
you are
stripping them
whoever it is beau bert marjorie taylor
green you're stripping them of their
committee assignments
you allow them to claim victim status
you allow them to martyr themselves and
they immediately start raising money on
it i've been cancelled and so on and so
forth and i want to say it again so that
people don't misunderstand
it's not wrong to remove them it's right
beaubert has no business being involved
in anything in washington dc
but what i'm wondering is what is truly
accomplished for example marjorie taylor
greene within hours of being stripped of
her committee assignments she was
fundraising she was sending out
fundraising emails saying they've
canceled me
donate in order to help me
do whatever i don't even know what the
argument was but it was they've canceled
me and give me money so i'm not arguing
that it's the wrong move it's the right
move on the merits
but what i'm wondering is whether
we end up helping republicans more than
hurting them when we do this to them
because they go to i've been canceled
and i told you that democrats cancel
people and now you've got to help me get
uncanceled for beau bert it's almost a
dream scenario
uh less work
she gets talked about in right-wing
media it gives her something to
fundraise on so what really needs to
happen is she's removed from congress
that's a much
tougher
and certainly much longer uphill battle
so let me know what you think net
benefit
or not
when these folks are removed from their
committee assignments
remember also tuesday december 14th 6 pm
eastern will be the next david pakman
show viewer town hall it will be the
last town hall of the year i hope you'll
join us it'll be streaming live on the
pacman live youtube channel that's the
second channel
very much looking forward to it there
are so many interesting new types of
assets in which you can invest at this
point there are sneakers there's wine
there's artwork and so many others but
the big question is which of these makes
sense as investments and that's why i am
such a big fan of alternative assets
which is one of our sponsors alternative
assets is a newsletter it's a newsletter
that will help demystify these different
investment markets whether you're
talking about video games or sports
cards
music rights comic books and the like
alternative assets is doing the analysis
about each of these different
asset types they do extremely deep
research and give very valuable insights
into them but alternative assets is not
just about
information it's also about results and
they have recommendations with an
excellent track record which you can
check out and learn more about on their
website
ton of smart new ways to diversify right
now it really is a different era when it
comes to investing and alternative
assets makes it very very easy to
understand
go and sign up for free the link is down
below